you go into a toilet go to the toilet
wash your hands and then open the door I
mean there's an argument that you should
be protecting your penis from your hands
that's what I mean that's what I mean so
I think the way the officer should be
managed is in the Pomodoro rhythm so the
the five breaks and then a 15-5 breaks
then lunch so for everyone should just
at the start of the day set out like
these are the tasks come here to do once
I've done the other you should be
punished if you if you are either under
providing tasks or not completely tasks
you set and rewarded if you more prefer
than other people because otherwise like
what does anybody do it Phillips sunrise
lamp it's got a very very low light way
of displaying the time at night I know
this sounds so for nikah tea but you
don't realize just how much light like a
normal LCD clock will actually give us
so if it's a [ __ ] red one and you're
like it this is brighter than it is
during the day like if it's all red you
feel like you're in a Tom Clancy movie
and then someone's gonna like Rainbow
six you Dorothy
ladies and gentlemen welcome back
it is life hacks 107 with Jonathan
Watson and Yousef from propane fitness
calm you know say boys and girls you as
you say ladies and gentlemen surely must
be 18 plus the follow fern is an adult
program for adult people it's a lie fact
it's been ages since we've done a live
fire house welcome guys it's been like
this is the first one of 2019 as well I
spoke to someone today on the phone it
was he said they loved my Fox and I told
him we're recording the next one today
and he's like I cannot wait it's getting
Cecily the best performing in terms of I
think it's just so actionable anyway um
first things first today's episode is
brought to you by the protein works if
you have a life hack that you want us to
try pop it in a comment below on YouTube
if you are just listening head to the
YouTube channel search mono mr. podcast
life hacks 107 and put your favorite
life hack in the comments below the best
life hack we will trial before the next
life hacks and do a review on it and
we're going to pick 150 pounds worth of
protein works product that will send you
for free
thank you very much the program works
for sponsoring this episode and I really
hope that the best one that gets chosen
isn't something weird that we have to do
but it might be I think you they should
be allowed to say specifically something
they want you to do okay if you would
like okay we can we can have that as a
little stipulate to be an all yeah - all
or - you sir
fine yeah but popular bullying terrible
and we do it and it wins you're getting
150 pounds worth of unflavored
[Laughter]
pick something good for us but yes pop
your favorite life hack in the comments
below
let's say if you're listening there is a
link to the YouTube channel in the show
notes head there give us a comment and
yeah well we'll pick someone should say
by the way hydrolyzed whey although it's
it's a very rapidly absorbed protein
hydrolysis is digestion and
tastes of vomit and when I say art it's
not like all of me to serve vomit is
horrible it actually tastes of um it is
what Tom it tastes like yeah the same
flavor fine right who is going to go
first show me a hot potato you Johnny or
what you always do
yep Johnny go on we did a podcaster
today with a guy who I didn't really
know much about you had a lot of
qualifications and loads of lesser must
open with got the podcast so my first
life hack is get a dog
nice so I the thing is to me and my
social circle it's like a not many
people I don't have dogs they'll be
people listen this you've liked how the
dr5 is [ __ ] you all about me how keep me
like yeah I got a dog first like don't
don't be that we trying to get one over
on me with you dog but you are the first
in in this circle that of getting a dog
yeah in there so it does just up level
the amount of time you smile enough
that's great which i think is worth i
mean they're expensive
I've seen the numerable benefits for you
in having Dexter mmm
I've seen a few downsides as well there
are deficits don't eat ones yeah so this
week he's been unwell which is men that
had to sleep on the sofa which has been
why because he was waking up to [ __ ] t
three times in the night okay so what's
getting sick I'm being sick so it's more
convenient to just be there literally
yeah it's like I was just limit my
downside this is a it's a really big
commitment it must be it's like the
tester for have a kid exactly so exactly
so how how you find me it because that
would be for me I'm especially for me as
well in any of the only children that
are listening will know the degree of
independence and non [ __ ] that you
give about the rest of the world and
things it's just you solo single dick
out swinging it round how has it been
having to not only be responsible for
another life but also think very
carefully about what someone else's
needs are it's a it's
visit really what's it like like you say
so it went from there's just me my
kettle firmer together and you just have
a life that you you don't even think
about like the little things in your
routine then suddenly this thing that's
like requires constant management like
doesn't have a bank like you can't do
anything himself can't feed himself I
have to do everything for him anything
he wants to cut up a pizza a [ __ ] like
either he does it in the house or I have
to say what right it's now time for ya
for your toilet time let's go do
something about that see ever and also
it's so it's made me really been
thinking this week actually so like
there was a night when both Becker and I
was that were sleeping on the sofa and
it's like we like scrunched on the sofa
and it's 3 a.m. and Dexter wakes up and
he's like barking needs to go out and
you hang on
you're both sleeping on the sofa you're
- I mean yeah respect to Beckett but
she's a longer yeah Anna and you are a
long wide human yep
how BIG's his sofa not big like not
picking up it's a dog on the sofa no the
dogs on the floor I think that you
taking liberties with your furniture
here mate
okay like I think if there are wide so
it's a bit like this where there's a
wide bone cushion for the sofa it is
this shape I should brush it did you
sleep at a right angle so one of us
sleeps that way one of the sleeps that
way yeah footies head to head feet it
yeah why I thought I just feels feels
not okay
what do you it is the worst combination
I think okay this is blunts this whole
situation has blown me away but that's
not the story so it sounds like that's
what would be doing and so if you wake
up at 3 in the morning and like neither
neither of you wants to wake up and do
it
but you've got to navigate that and so
like I can that's that's quite testing
on a relationship because I can only
imagine like that's like a week of six
months of having you or not that has a
long time and I suppose a dog's life
span it like they grow more rapidly yeah
yeah so that period of time dissipates
very quickly maybe like I don't know
TV is when your kid if I'm gonna wake up
from the other night and stuff like that
you I thought we were maybe a bit less I
think based on it almost feels like you
should if you think about having a kid
you should be made fast dog versus and
then like if your relationship lasts
that let me serve as well then so good
prep for having a kid improves the
amount of laughs and smiles in your
heart it's got you out the house more as
well actually houses its the outdoor
thing for me would be obscene would be
as little so steps it's necessary ten
thousand consistently the ten thousand
is a lot of steps as well so there is in
atomic habits we James clear he talks
about I want to say it's strategic
choices or choice a crucial choices with
a downstream implication I cannot
remember the specific term the users but
he talks about single purchase or single
decisions which have multiple downstream
benefits and the first one and this book
is like the [ __ ] Bible for habit
setting not read something that's so
implementable and is very good and then
the top one is if your area that you're
looking to improve on its happiness by
dog just get a dog like I mean if if
James [ __ ] clear says it yeah well so
it does definitely like it's a it is a
lifestyle increase but there's just a
cost with that you have that increase so
you need to be asymmetric I'm gonna get
yeah but things like so the stuff I
thought it would it would knock and
right to this is stuff like I'll never
get the Rawat again like I'll never you
know my mornings will be trapped as you
do it with you so this morning he
actually did yeah yeah but I'm gonna
puppy dog but so he's [ __ ] obviously
brilliant the puppy dog like he owns
that that's his post because downward
dog it to be weirdly
he doesn't do proper downward dog
because he's a puppy right so he does a
proper and he gets his head all the way
through in my father so I got you know
I'm really how that's are so tight yeah
but Daniel if you are listening Daniel
voices ROM um can we have dog water
please dunk Ward would be good
split-screen
[ __ ] mints that really good they do
dog yoga
I think [ __ ] knows what that involves
for
but so actually you I have to do all
that stuff so I have to meditate Ronald
whatever before a certain time what he
needs to be out so it's actually created
like just an unavoidable I can't get out
of it like that's non-negotiable
so you've Parkinson law time box do more
than routine yeah but I suppose the one
problem is that if you have a very
naughty dog or one that's chaotic with
its sleeping routine if it gets up at
five one day seven the next eight the
neck yeah yeah doctor very dogs thrive
off routine is it true if you keep a dog
in a routine especially it's a puppy and
you you create a routine of the dog it
just so interestingly so they've
actually had a benefit from routine
izing your life their causes around the
dog around the dog that's great so if
you like a lot of people you have a dog
on work nine to five and come home at
lunch or whatever if they then work from
home in the morning they'll find the dog
to sleep till morning because that's
what it's being used to do again and it
plays an evening order so yeah so it's
quite expensive more expensive than how
I thought it was gonna be insurance dog
food the things add up
the other thing that is really annoying
is the way that vets pricing works so
you'll be in the vets with dog and
they'll go are we'll just go run test
test test and as you leave the
receptionist goes only hundred and
twenty pounds here and what what do you
mean like no one mentioned like I can't
refund it because it's happened yeah so
either I'm at I'm in debt to you he's
put the air pods in your pocket and you
know it's out of the store and someone's
come running out there and the receipt I
know is that is that upsells or is that
you can sold stuff without realizing
you've agreed to it yeah well it's like
you so in the same way so imagine you go
to a doctor and you're like my stomach
in it and they do test 1 test 2 test 3
test 4 and then as you leave you get
charged for those I say well haven't I
only one that's why but at no point did
the doctor say I'm gonna do this is this
it's gonna be don't say which is a
mandatory yeah it's just like oh well it
could be a spectrum of problems I'll
test for all of them bill you for all of
them cheers man I mean I'm an MRI they
need to make money yeah surely you can
just do you like I suppose that's what
the American system is like this so you
come in with a sore finger and they will
do like a CT head and
really yeah there's fully so Jen
generator I think really well cuz then
the incentives are aligned hmm you'd
rather the the the doctor like it
radiates you head to toe this is
rationale behind this PR exam like
obviously if you taking the piss then
that's different
I see but if the incentive is so what
stop them taking the piss their time I
suppose and also a finding said so
they're getting paid for the time then
like I've got a patient in I'll just you
know I don't know I'm okay I probably
took the picture that direction the
other what then just be like I get
rather a doctor just gets me out of the
room because the 10 minutes are up I'd
rather that didn't happen and instead
I'm Center for the foot over a full
blood panel okay so by dog see what
about you first just on the back of that
as well if you don't commit to a dog or
if you can't afford the the long-term
cost of the dog borrow my doggy calm
excellent website where thanks 12 pounds
a year and you just you basically select
dogs within your like tinder for dogs I
suppose so like you you look at dogs
within your range within you like your
locality
rate choose the gender choose Jan shows
the age I mean yeah he's a pretty she's
the type of dog people have a little dog
profile photos and you just borrow
someone's dog if they're going away or
if there is anyone uploaded a photo of a
dog with the dog felt that from snap
Charlotte because I'm choose that dog
definitely dog dogs quite a good time
yeah yeah is that where we got the
Whippet that had psychomotor retardation
but that was a friend but I've borrowed
other dogs from borrow my doggie and
they were much better I don't like
history television I do think that
getting it getting a dog but in life is
like if you're out the house a lot yeah
exactly so that this is the reason I
like I I've grown up with dogs and I'm
sure like a lot of people especially
young people though listening will think
like [ __ ] I've grew up with dogs I love
dogs too bit yeah and it like makes me
physically emotionally
ride when I see dogs I just want to be
around them yeah but because I have so
much respect for them and I know based
on my mom and dad's treatment of our
dogs what
level of activity and care dogs should
have and they can have I'm like I'm not
gonna take this dog like a perfect
example point today it's disservice to
the dog if you're out there household
just check it because the dog doesn't
have the choice it can't go and complain
to some exactly
and like the proofs in the pudding are
robbed are wanna collie is nearly 16
yeah any like that's what happens when
you get walked three times a day and you
have a militarized food and wake routine
yeah yeah like yeah right like how so my
life I've got mine divided into physical
and digital so my first physical life
hack is this was a suggestion actually
from a guy called dun dun this was
fantastic and giving me 3 is if you have
a accident in the car or an altercation
or a road rage situation so like someone
starts getting out of car coming towards
you
you fought out on them instantly defuses
the situation or because what about does
is shows a merit to them they're not
gonna be winter trying to like aggravate
you now I hang on sometimes me I'm gonna
be a meme here yeah they just see
themself and they're like oh man what
was that the guy you're the like BBC man
who tell you what you are - what was he
saying
and I mean it's like a David out
appetite guy oh my gosh this [ __ ] on a
motorway I've seen the one where the
there's a cyclist coming along in the
guys in the car and he's being super
super angry and very very threatening
then gets out of the car and the
cyclists start cycling away and the guy
runs along tries to kick him that's
poetry that video video guiding will put
the slow-mo you show me advice so
someone's I fooled I dissected the video
I'm just reading my frame so that
there's a minute where he's like he's
talking to him and you are you attack no
are you a car no you're a cyclist so get
off the water on route doesn't pay road
tax
and then I saw the most beautiful phrase
in the English language I've ever
witnessed
[Music]
it is the phrase put your [ __ ] mouth
in the middle of the face and shoulder
in the ground yeah yeah it's
unbelievable right okay so film and
that's opposed any phone any time
there's a fight just film just start
filming
yes that's it the car and prepare to die
he's in the car park somewhere isn't it
right you've got a great YouTube channel
the starting of a great YouTube channel
or you've defuse the fight yeah no
downside yeah lost dashcam million views
yeah it's good right
so my first one is using scissors in the
kitchen for everything you use a knife
for okay so these straight straight off
the but like if you are still cutting
chicken with a knife like give up yeah
like by a fairly okay pair of kitchen
scissors need to be quite sharp and
you'll just you never need to use
truckers chicken is out chicken is on
your hands both hands usually you're
holding it might chop your finger then
you've got like Salmonella in your wound
nothing worse yeah Salmonella wound
where is you can have single hand over
the pot chopping away chopping your
chicken into little dicey strips or
whatever it is the same goes for
vegetables the same goes for pizza like
pizza with a pair of scissors like just
[ __ ] e people attract you know like when
the astronauts went to space and they
were like there's no gravity in space we
need to come up with a pen that will
write upside down psych it's a pencil
like yes mate [ __ ] real writer
the Americans invested and money in the
like the Space Pen and then Russians
just use a pencil to buy the space
papers you use it underwater upside down
sold so well if people just want it's a
novelty yeah yeah I remember like j ml
or QVC us along being like it could ride
on walls and it writes upside-down yeah
[ __ ] off me I'll just have a pencil
please HP on HB 3 thanks remember boys
stuff the website that used to be an OK
yeah is that like fire box I think most
of sound like the e guns and yeah yeah
yeah they were all over that kind of
thing but yeah scissors I mean is there
anything that you guys used scissors for
that's right yeah like you're right
kitchen stuff because that chicken how
long is it take the try and cut chicken
up we can just go and then you can get
more accuracy less injury risk that's
why I sing it you do the other thing as
well is and I always think this about
when I go in the bathroom and it's an
odd habit of mine but I when I go to the
bathroom I only use left hand like if
it's a number one and like I'm just left
hand like I've grown up doing things
with my right hand holding stuff in
clubs on the clipboard on the phone
doing whatever does that mean that I
only need to wash one hand because I
don't but I feel like I wasted however
when I'm in the kitchen and I'm cutting
chicken you know I've only touched
chicken with one hand but I still wash
both you're very arid so it is Arab
cultural thing to only do unsanitary
things with the LAT pants while you
shake out really right yeah so like in
our culture if you like if you do
something if you like touch something
with your left hand I don't know if you
like it yeah
isn't it something like you need the
germs you actually get from touching
your penis having a wee and a smaller
than like we get from Ebola nuts on a
barrage
the both of us in the bar isn't absolute
like ecosystem of even so that so the
irony of like you go into a toilet go at
the toilet wash your hands and then open
the door yeah as well I mean there's an
argument that you should be protecting
your penis from your hands that's what I
mean yeah like there's more stuff that
can go wrong this is a serious I need
something to say hmm
because it does seem to me I'm standing
in a public toilet and I will see
someone have a piss and then leave
without washing hands you think like
don't be such a [ __ ] nine-year-old at
least do you think you're how busy is
your life that you don't have enough
time to wash your hands do you know what
is a and I will I will make this
argument it is painful if you mid Jim
set and you're chalky and I by optimal
level of chalk on your hands but you
need to wait and you're like I've got to
get back to this degree of dryness and
shortness is like a it's a four-minute
job washing your hands can be mean
missing the next set yeah I go out all
grip calm doesn't matter what I'm
actually gonna do a double because this
one's pretty much the same okay um using
a plastic bottle to get the yolk out of
eggs we take a squeezy yeah okay if I
see that before it's a very YouTube like
suck it suck it up yeah
have you tried it so I found weirdly
that the best thing for dealing with egg
is egg shell so you know scoop a you
know if you crack an egg into a pan yeah
and there's a bit of shell yeah the best
thing to get that out yeah is extra okay
fair enough
and also crack the egg and I just do tip
it between the two yeah tip two this is
up I mean if it's obviously that he's
going pop and then it's just stay in the
bottle unbelievable you wouldn't need
any multiple
oh yeah it's a so you can imagine you've
cracked the egg obviously the one time
this doesn't work if you're frying any
crack me into a pan because once it
starts cooking you [ __ ] yeah but so
you need to crack it into whatever it is
that you put in it
squeeze the bottle just allow the tip to
touch the top of it just like release it
no yeah
sucks back and then what happens with
egg nama team is it keeps on just
doesn't be bad on the second egg when
you squeeze
does it not squeeze some of your corn on
to you so you are getting it they go so
they go so that scissors and let me
about to say something that's right
Johnny where we go nice gusto or
hellofresh
okay mmm that's it
North pasture man carrying a booster box
oh we're here oh they both are same I
like blue apron in America I've been
pretty pretty similar Yeah right
I would say Gusteau's better based on
heavy tripod Cody's fella G oh you sto
so my diet probably the same for both of
you extremely bland I know you're you
both in the slow cooker and you says
maybe a bit better than mine extremely
bland eat the same things every day went
back where I eat together it's the same
[ __ ] every time so this but then we both
have like their I'd quite like to learn
to cook I'd quite like to do it more
cooking but and even by a recipe book
but like them the barrier like you open
it you're like one clove of garlic one
bit of ginger
you just has like ginger in the house
and maybe you do I don't know who has
like exactly the right amount of Zen he
does so I've cut out oh I've got a big
bag of blocks of frozen ginger and
frozen garlic so I just chuck them in
the slow cooker okay when it which is
lovely that lists are very ok because he
Tesco do like a sachet who have like
crushed garlic but it's really steep and
it's tiny it's very expensive and if you
go goes by the Indian section even in
Arkham orisons or you know Indian
supermarket you get a kilogram bag of
garlic blocks or ginger
there's such good so I'm actually amazed
at how many recipes have ginger in them
there's so many more than you'd expect
it's a great flavor and even just like
sauces that you just take for granted
what actually goes into making that I
[ __ ] out so 15 minutes of just
chopping and dicing just and making
sauce
anyway so that's a little more you get
it that you get a mass election of
things you can pick from the side of the
week you pick the recipes that you like
the most
they deliver exactly the right amount
the right ingredients for that with
recipe cards - so does that machine
learn like where oh that's okay so like
this is for me that's the thing
I made chicken korma from scratch by
I've had different types of curry that
never had before you can just remove the
nuts from the preparation it's a way for
you this is a convoluted way to for you
to ensure that there's no nuts in you
float it is yeah it is and also so I
always feel bad for you that you can't
have Indian food because of the business
of about it we can't we can't go to chop
prior which is a crying shame yeah I'd
love it Ali yeah I'm sure it would kill
both of us at the time he was like I'd
be great about oysters and be dead and
you developed and be dead but so so
anyone who it works best for like two or
three or four people okay and if you are
Arthur wait you can still do it I think
with the portion sizes Chrissie yeah
we've seen a hospital away they're not a
lot of yogurt in us in a serene in about
20 thought between boosters the soaring
in the yogurt and the yogurt snot like
it's not petty falou it's a share yogurt
like a kilo type of yogurt carbs are
like the the meals are on average 600
taken recoveries cook per serving per
serving yeah and then won't be two
servings so you could risk laughs in the
face yeah yeah no calories really good
like the stuff that I've eaten over the
past three weeks for dinner I would
never
what would you if it can you pick like
if someone's gonna go cuz I'm gonna
guess they'll be referral you got a
referral code but you don't I do you
here fantastic referral code will be
below I'm gonna guess you'll get one
free meal no what are your bill this is
when he's smart too so if someone's
gonna if someone's potential
gonna go and get a ghost or whatever it
is cousteau gusto what meals would you
recommend difficulty as they change
every week busted so that to be honest
is great there's always variations on
the theme so the Xindian week is a taco
well no so there's like so there's
always like if every door at the taco
one is always a burger there's always a
make-your-own-pizza there's always carry
variations
it's like mousakas this is a horrible
like I think one we've just selected is
like what Celina peanut pure a peanut
Palais de chickens peanut salad and
peanut chicken with relish with its
little peanut sauce here how much is it
McCarney chicken McCarney and a one-pot
Mexican beef rice and beans the tea that
I picked okay well I mean the chance of
you ever eating now or cooking that what
precisely precisely so and the nice
thing about it is that the cards they
give you the recipe cards a hole punched
so we're gonna keep the recipe cards and
then over time you can accumulate like
what you suppose you think like I need
this much garlic and ginger for these
recipe C star trek Elin - and they're
all they've all got the macros and it's
all in my fitness pal
these pits really good that's awesome
and that's got GU GG oh you sto can you
find you a referral company I'll send it
to you good use of Europe so I've got
another physical one oh yeah so did you
tell digital corporate heap dental floss
in the shower you know where were you
where you have all the stuff to hang the
shower gels okay because flossing is one
of those things that you just never get
around to doing whereas you're not doing
anything in the shower you're just
standing there getting wet and warm so a
lot of em to floss it also it means when
you spit out all the blood and stuff it
just goes off in the shower drains away
so we spoke to Dean Sam Mart recently
they said that the largest source of
systemic inflammation in the body
it's from your gums and because most
people are terrible at flossing there's
a huge low-hanging fruit with flossing
and that brings down your CRP which is
the inflammatory marker produced by you
liver and that bringing that down
correlates with better body composition
better mood lower stress all those
things so yeah so [ __ ] knows this
happened with me saying to him because
he was like depression has got I did I
just talk of either no just stuff I just
had this thought as I excited speaking
as I get that I just completely lost it
um so I said he was like you people have
a I get this wrong genetic
predisposition to depression yeah okay I
said like if you have that what can you
do
he said well you manage your information
I was like fine how do you manage your
promotion you say we're flossing so
you're telling me mate that if I just
floss my teeth in less depression less
likely get the fracture thing okay hope
he's not watching terrible busy yeah so
philosophies of using this good so do
you use um DS mouthwash occasionally so
for me I've managed to get myself into
the rhythm that the degree of cleanness
that I'm happy with for my teeth now is
mouthwash clean so that you know how I
don't get how some people are able to
leave the house without cleaning my
teeth yeah for me there's it's the same
as walking out the house feet without
your shoes on
I just glad I'm not ready to go like and
there is part of me that isn't done mmm
I'd be like walking out with no pants on
or something like that and for me now
the bar for cleanliness for mouth has
been raised up to like green blue
Listerine which is like the Hat one no
provocateurs to render the original
flavor Listerine that's a yeah it's not
hard for a change the color he used to
be yellow just like originally had no
bleach Li
oh no this that might be a bit more or
some purple whatever do you meet that
one well you want your how a mouth to be
on fire yeah but yeah so they've / safai
dit recently my honestly that they're
like the one in the 1990s back in when
Old Spice was like a scoop that you have
to lather are they were just use
Brylcreem yeah surreal no someone
[ __ ] requested on a photo shoot the
other day anyways what broke Brylcreem
yeah what do you style your hair with
and I saw her on the coal sheet one of
the male models had requested Brylcreem
as it come on it was invited David
Beckham with it 2019 so with the dental
floss thing I you always knew that I
should floss at the back of my mind
admittedly Dean smart is like fully
convinced me to do that not but even
knowing that no one needs convincing of
the benefits but it's like it's not
something you really get around to doing
it and how do I draw our sight never
really got around to it whereas now in
the showers oh great everybody's my cuz
you can get like a mint yeah or will be
sat in one just because yeah if you got
a cheap one it ends up like catching and
fraying and then you get little bit
stuck in your suit but it's just paper
you get like 20 meters of serving in
this what 40 50 meters yes so you may as
well pay 3 pounds like an extra 40 P or
something for the nice one and that was
I think one on behalf of year something
like yeah and if you get a minty one
like obviously there will be a residual
taste of the plaque that you're clearing
out from in between the teeth and if you
use an unflavored one then there's still
gonna be that sense
so should you should you floss before
you clean your teeth because I tend to
clean my teeth and get a shower
mmm so I don't know and I'm gonna
presume that you must have to floss
first then clean their mouth watering
all that yeah I've got a few dentist
friends that are very specific about the
order of this stuff because there are bu
injuries as bacteremia when you floss
and so it has to be the frequency of
this and then you gotta leave the
fluoride to can talk into the teeth for
this much time and don't have sugar
within this much today can brighten if
you're there so final tip for flossing
rather than like trying to fiddle around
with each tooth take care strip this
long wrap it I'll often rather foot
probably wrap it around both index
fingers three like you're like you're a
Turkish man about to thread someone's
eyebrows yeah like a retort man or a hit
man about a grouse and then start at the
very back both both teeth up at the top
okay and just work through so you're
doubling your doubling your efficiency
with flossing and Oviedo back in and as
one is a little side to side to get it
in
they sake don't saw through the gums
yeah is it just once in and then all the
way forward and then yeah come on you
[Music]
should be able to yeah yeah yeah if your
problems got me on social media and tell
me about your job problems that make you
feel better I'm gonna stay in the
kitchen for mine staying in the kitchen
okay today do you know the correct way
to cut the cake I'm probably doing it
all wrong about this is one of those
things like tying your shoelaces were
actually you realize all your life
you've been when you say the correct way
or the most effective way to keep
freshness no so you've got a cake of any
shape of a cake of most chips I'm gonna
guess there'll be some it's an octagonal
shape that I
three tetrahedrons inside of it not
actually it's more effective to go from
the Northern Quarter but so what you
want to do most people in a get cake
they'll cut a little wedge out right so
you go from the middle down like classic
birthday cake right mother or mother at
birthday party
wedge down wedge out again and then from
that the line that's been made you'll
continue to cut one wedge all the way
around until the cakes go but you have
no way of protecting the sponginess the
lovely soft sponginess inside from the
air outside which is when you then need
to cling film over the top however if
you have a cake circular or square or
whatever it might be like that and you
cut a complete line from one side right
the way to the other then you can and
then you just slide the rest of the cake
together the icing around the outside
will continue to protect it and it will
still all of the lovely soft sponginess
will be hermetically sealed inside by
the icing so there's a problem that I
see with that which is as you approach
the end of the cake you end up with the
final two slices being almost
exclusively icing fun fine so although I
suppose you can look forward to nice
hold on hold on there's a circle cake
yes right are you cutting a line or you
cutting a piece do you by sight you
saying you bisects the whole cake across
the diameter young you move bits in so
you're gonna make two parallel lines the
width that you want and then go you end
up with a really weird slice of cake I
see I saw you're not you're gonna end up
with a perfectly straight slice of can
you know end up with it with you know
you know sometimes you go to a birthday
party where there's like 40 kids there
yeah and you end up and he went like
Cocos are lazy quasi and you end up with
it with a slice of cake the focus on
this the slices of the wedge yeah better
but it's something with a proper cake
Tony because no actually we were exposed
to professionals from very young ages
occasionally you'd get a slice of cake
that was really icing II yeah
and then you you are right you have you
have identified that as you get more
towards the crust at the very end at
slither of cake in a big bill no I mean
who doesn't want that actually you led
you to marzipan no Hartman's Hartman's
okay the islands are more that's a fun
so I only know that I so funny story I
only know that because this is it I was
sat in uni so me Dom audio broadcast
Gibson digital right Lewis at play
called Judy on three separate TVs it on
the same Wi-Fi just preventing anybody
from being able to access the the VLE or
any or anything thing they needed to do
and I said you know what [ __ ] this I'm
sick of this drove to the core picked up
hazelnuts walnuts almonds gave Dom the
EpiPen and said I'm gonna work through
these while playing Cod if I have a
reaction negligent Oh God God forgot
what did almonds did walnuts but wait
them all both fight night one then a
couple more okay same with walnuts
thought three times in a row seemed a
bit a bit much I'll not bother with it
isn't that same brush and relax yeah
what I've happened had you have eaten
hazel sorry I don't know but I think
I've never the other fella I think I
probably have by accent yeah okay it's a
bit of a fitness II thing right
very fitness right Johnny you're I am so
fitness Johnny come on did my done I'm
creating the show notes is we can really
live life hacked the life hacks amazing
three things per day one thing per week
giveaway no do complete and so anything
for day of many things yeah so but
called essentialism but called the one
thing basically all attack the same
thing which is that like a focus
procrastination being ineffective
etc come from just trying to do too many
things and being diffusely focused so
each week pick a thing like a project
that you're gonna move forward a
complete and then at the start of each
day
look at you to-do list and pick three
things and do those three things every
single day and it sounds insanely simple
really difficult give me any
example of three things so that'll be
like work-related for me because it
might be sent to marketing emails finish
off a certain piece of automation or
software right piece of content so it's
not stuff that would be it's not stuff
that like you are doing all the time
recurring something low level tasks and
stuff that if you didn't make time to do
it
we probably wouldn't get done do you
think one thing very well for you what
do you think this this works
particularly well in a job where you
have like consistent categories of tasks
that come up for instance if you are
someone that works in customer service
or something like me which is very
responsive mm-hmm if the majority of
your job is conflict management or
problem solving so maybe not in that
instance yeah I'm just trying to fit I'm
trying to sit it's but it's for stuff so
something that you have spec on is the
Eisenhower matrix so anything that's in
agent not urgent but it warned so stuff
there like stuff that we procrastinate
on yeah essentially if you make time for
things like that don't helps yeah but
like if all of your job is just in the
urgent unimportant category and
everything has to be done now
yeah then yeah but it like says me I
most people in knowledge work so you are
producing something physical
procrastination [ __ ] constantly hundred
percent and even students like pick
three lectures you want to do today or
pick a lecture you want to do this week
and then slides you want you know like
it's just it's just chunking things and
also like there are apps you can use to
track this I like to do is you can set a
task goal for the day so when you've
done three or three things
it goes on congratulations and but doing
if you do the work during the work we
can you do fifteen things a week fifty
many things and one big thing that's a
shit-ton and most people can't look back
over the past week and say these are the
fifteen but relatively important things
I did yeah so it's just having having
some direction and purpose with what you
do day that's good
so to take off on that and to explain
further on the mm on the Eisenhower
matrix it is you have a quadrant four
quadrants of urgent and important see
how urgency and you have importance
urgent and important urgent and not
important important but not urgent and
not urgent not important so there's the
four quadrants with important and urgent
you do them right away with important
but not urgent you schedule them to do
them at some point in the future with
not important and urgent you delegate
and with not important not urgent you
just sack them off so could you could
you give a type of example of a task
that might form to each one yes oh so
urgent unimportant
so for who's who's the who's the Avatar
here that a desk worker
that's job okay so or you just you
that's it whatever okay for a desk
worker you've got like urgent
unimportant you have a project that is
due tomorrow and it's a presentation
that has to be done you need to do it
because it requires you or knowledge or
expertise and it can't wait until next
week so you just you prioritize that you
do that immediately urgent and not
important that might be some tasks that
may be the intern could do if you just
like spent 10 minutes with them explain
what they need to do work through some
it's like some cove-man awesomeness task
that has to be done but it's not really
top of your priorities so you just you
showed you in a time to speak to them
and then you dedicate that for the
important but not urgent stuff that
might be stuff that actually progresses
your career long-term that's the danger
zone there's and a danger zone doing
building skills and it's stuff that it's
so easy to just put it off because you
think oh well there's no real
consequence if I don't do this it's not
in the short-term but long-term if you
don't if you neglect the stuff that is
important and not urgent then your whole
life starts to just trundle along and be
crap so that's the stuff you need to
shed you'll in and dedicate time on a
weekend or whatever to do which might be
like reading improving yourself training
or the like training is a very good
example actually
it's CPD of something yeah a CPD like
because there's no there's no
consequence of not doing it there's no
immediate gain from doing it but it
builds up and create gems clear a lot of
people in that least that I speak to in
desk jobs the stuff that would fit into
that categories exactly that sort of
thing like I want to learn to code or I
want to take watercolor classes you know
I [ __ ] that if you don't think right I'm
gonna do this tonight or the Joker I've
done that's been good for that Coursera
okay yeah that like you do me it's
similar to udemy or great courses plus
but it it's like so I went and I did a
big analysis of all of this at the start
of the year I wanted to formalize my
learning so that I was accountable to an
external time line and they have like
week by week by week modules that you're
moving through and if you start fall
behind they give you emails and stuff
like that okay
Coursera seemed to be as far as I could
see one of the most sophisticated like
you demeans got some good stuff on great
great courses plus just seems to be like
for people from youtube to sheriff
referral links to and doesn't really
look like there's that much good stuff
on there but cousin master class as well
[ __ ] I'm gonna guess this loads things
because I nearly Oh grams going through
the cookery only and I cook
Gordon Ramsay has a master class thing
though really Horned requited something
no I'm guessing course areas like vetted
and it's been it's it's really dude it's
issued by actually unis but they have
the most popular MOOC massive open
online course right in the world the
best and it's free whoa so it's
interesting the accountability is very
important there I think like something
that George said to the other day was
that he wanted to set up some
dropshipping project and he was like I'm
not good I don't want to speak to you
about the specifics yet because I've not
taken action and I know that I I'm the
kind of person that gets the same hit
from talking about doing something as I
do from actually doing it and so that's
that's like just kind of talking about
doing a thing but if you have a course
where it's like you need to check in
with it with a coach or you need to take
something off then it gets rid of iron
is like you have to actually do the
thing so what's not important to not
urge
that's just stuff that that maybe it may
masquerade as important not urgent so
the development stuff but you look at
anything actually this isn't gonna add
much value to my life but it's just
hanging over my head the Warren Buffett
thing where he said to his pilot what
are the 25 things you want to achieve in
in your career and he was is all this
stuff in is that right tape number 5 to
25 and put all that stuff on you do not
ever do under anything that's gonna do
is crowd your your thinking and you know
the essentialism I Spencer you example
isn't where it's like you just needs to
have a single focus so I'm terrible with
that I've got too many things on I'm
always trying to do too much stuff and
so the eisenhower matrix has been a huge
improvement for me and so the life hack
is an app called focus matrix which is
it's free there's lots of paid ones as
well but I think all you need is a free
one it's literally just like a to-do
list and four quadrants color coded and
you can add little sub notes into the
to-do list and it's just completely
helped easy - is that the same some
girls be focused Pro it is yes excise
syncs with baptizes yes he combined a
savvy focus pros a Pomodoro timer and so
you can buy the suite and they're all
like to put each or something so you can
definitely viral all the line yeah and
then they just sync with each other so
you can take a task say right start
Pomodoro's on this and then it works
through any tracks the Pomodoro is in
each segment as well lovely yeah that's
right okay so I don't think that we've
actually properly done Pomodoro's and
how big of a a change it's been for me
have we not no not not properly I was
going to do it in Taiwan unlike
productivity and stuff like that I'm
realizing we're making so many
references to things like saying
Pomodoro
if the other pond oh yeah what's that
yeah
so D'Amato food Italian tell me tomorrow
what's eat and normal so Thomas hearth
Pomodoro's are for me have been probably
the single biggest shift in work and how
I schedule my time when I'm at work
doing some form of work I've ever had
like this it's the same as I just I
start thinking about this yesterday I
don't know why I can't understand how
other people construct their working day
without doing it this is how big of a
frameshift using the bit I'm gonna guess
they've similar for you guys now as well
like that if you're not you know such a
great metric it's like I see when you do
something and you're like how do people
live without this automatic automatic
cars literally here it's what the [ __ ]
you doing what like you put your foot to
the floor and you move your hand to
choose the gear well like like a [ __ ]
knee underthrown thank is the thing I
may catch in your own butter as well
it's a poor nuts was the extension of
that was like cuz people say oh no you
know I like change my gears I said well
where does that stop like well I'm gonna
get out and push the car or I'm gonna
get out and start the car manually
myself for why the windscreen why I'm
gonna make my own fuel from crush them
all material manly is lifting the
driving experience a little girl if you
drive it that bad can change gear faster
than you cut carbs does it yeah hmm
there's a guy on a speed awareness
course where someone I thought I was on
the speedboat at school as someone was
like the instruction was was talking
about what gear to choose going downhill
never busy
he's a I drive a manual car so i driving
automatic cop he's like well yes that
would do it for you so what's the point
in this [ __ ] segment limo buddy at
least half the people of this room will
have and they should do or they should
have less than a life hacks 101 and so
Pomodoro um essentially you do a
25-minute period of focused work you
take a five minute break
and then you go back to doing your work
it sounds pretty simple and if you
create a list of all the things that you
have to do you then order them in order
of importance and then there's one task
that you're working on at one time so it
avoids the multitasking issue that a lot
of us come up against which is what
derails you I'll do a little bit of this
and I'll do a little bit that it's like
no no no no you begin down your list of
priority you start the top and you begin
to move down one thing that I've liked
particularly like to do is to use the
Zeigarnik effect open-loop closed-loop
in collaboration with the Pomodoro
Technique which is that when my alarm
goes off to say that at the end of 25
minutes even if I'm partway through a
word it'll be hands off keyboard and yep
yes fine I will sell them one of the
advantages of that is that when I come
back to begin my work you can always
finish the word yeah that open-loop
these small back into the work whereas
if you allow yourself to complete it
feels like more of a bookend so
Parkinson's Law work expands to fill the
time given for it time boxing also makes
you accountable externally to the clock
if you use be focused Pro which will be
linked in the show notes below if you
use that there's a little timer on
MacBook which counts down from 25 which
also makes you accountable and it's just
a little bit like the analogy a draw to
meditation is when you return to the
breath or when you realize that you've
been lost in thought like you'll do
something and it's a little red clock
that's not that distracting but it's
distracting enough for if you're not
doing the task that you're supposed to
be doing if you think of a [ __ ] like
I've got 60 minutes left and you do like
those little periods you can tie this in
with professor human Lawson from episode
17 his 20-20-20 rule so every 20 minutes
for 20 seconds like it's something
that's 20 feet away which helps to reset
the ocular muscles so that you don't get
too much eye strain it's also good for
if you have stretching that you need to
do throughout the day like little bits
of exercises it ensures like if you get
in a good enough routine with it you can
have all I'm going to have my water
consumption
certainly accountable to my Pomodoro's
my stretchings accountable to my
Pomodoro's if you charge your air pods
when you're doing a Pomodoro's you'll
never run out of air pod charge like
there's so many different things that
you can do and before the EPI focus Pro
has the time of 4:15 are at 25 on then 5
off and then for me I've got every for a
15-minute break during my Pomodoro break
time which means that you can go that
for me is also externally accountable
every 15 minute one for me is a walk
that I know takes 10 minutes plus I've
got 2 minutes put my shoes on take them
off it come back in and have a glass of
water and the shift is it's nothing
short of global like in terms of life I
think the reason that you know you say
my how do people manage that they
otherwise I honestly think that so I
worked in a coffee shop with a friend
who works in the work sense accounting
in a business and I said to him like I
used to do I used to work at KPMG with
him we used to revise the you know words
in the coffee shop you mean you would
when we were both on a laptop in the
coffee shop yes folio espresso to
Pomodoro's so we used to do we serve
eyes together for us and exactly
supervisor Pomodoro's and so when he was
working with me will be doing pompadoras
together and after two Pomodoro's he
said to me that is the most
uninterrupted work I've done for as long
as I can remember she's constantly
getting people asking him slow for
questions and I think the way the
average person gets her workday is
they're in an office and it's very very
disruptive environment and there's very
little intense work and I find that so
weird to think back to that's how it
used to work bizarre like for me like 8
Pomodoro's at work or 12 hours of work
in a day is a lot of work yeah but to do
less than that most people do like two
or three and like well how do you get by
with that but that's how it's just you
can't have that was probably part of our
scripture it is bizarre to think that
most office structures especially when
you've got that we've got a couple of
friends who work in kind of like new New
Wave gen-y offices that are all open
plan with like
cool sound systems and this than us
return from the walls yeah and all that
I think is all I think is put me in the
quietest smallest cubicle Tammi to a
cabin yeah no Wi-Fi yeah put me lock me
in there and then for the five minutes
during my thing and give me a yoga mat
and give me some other people hey man
how's it going oh here's a dog here's
like loads of stimulus like great and
then I'm like they're all waiting at
there and then vac it so I think the way
the officers should be managed is in the
Pomodoro at the rhythm so the the fire
breaks and then a 15-5 breaks and lunch
we need to talk about this for the Cal
Newport deep work review well it's late
because he slates open-plan offices for
just like the fact that yeah there's
been open plan there's a movement saw
was instant-messaging and everything is
just completely degrading the senses
what insulting as well is when there's a
culture that those people work late yeah
I there is zero respect for anybody's
time in this setup like so true you take
you other words need to go to Vegas work
wasn't fur so everyone should just at
the start of the day set out like these
are the tasks come here to do once I've
done them once I've done them over and
then you should be and leave me alone
well sure you should be punished if you
if you are either under providing tasks
or not completely tasks you set and
rewarded if you more put up for than
other people yeah because otherwise like
what does anybody do it well it's this
it's like staring it what it what one of
the main problems with this is that you
need to be able and this is why you have
pay banned right and unfortunately
there's a there's like I don't know what
that particular mind experiment would be
but it'll be similar to kinda like the
prisoner's dilemma well you've got
there'll be some people that will do
less and get dragged along and there's
some people will do more and they will
drag the others but both of those people
are on the same payment essentially
everyone should be on as far as I'm
concerned everyone that's a knowledge
worker should be on performance-based
pay you like right okay if you can get
your work done in this time and if
someone says I work that from home allow
them to work from home yeah well this is
part right a 4-hour work week idea
review convince your boss
you can take a couple of days to work
from home and then you outperform your
other days when you're working from home
you can then say well look look at my
net look at my numbers I've been
performing better on Thursday when I was
off and then working from home so can i
and you were saying that the the
incentives are so misaligned at KPMG
because you've finished the you finish
the tasks for the day and then you're
just given more stuff like you were in
order for completing the work so that if
the nine-to-five model is like if you've
done you work by 3:00 you'll just be
given more work so in that that's work
that may have been allocated to someone
else who's had a really unproductive day
so you're just you're punished to being
productive
but the biggest criticism I hear for
this stuff is yeah but my job involves
management or there's meetings and I
need to communicate with people but all
that stuff would still be more outcome
focus than it is
so I'm perfect avatar for that like a
lot of my stuff's response I mean yeah
requiring we are literally just managing
people on you yeah constantly yeah all
the time
but even with that like I'll sit down
with the lads and the boys have got the
boys eating Pomodoro's now so they're
doing their uni recruitment and the
revision and all that sort of stuff in
in poverty which is also definitely one
thing and I'm gonna guess that you guys
will stick to it but I still stick to
David Allen's two-minute rule even when
doing Pomodoro's and so if a task takes
a lot I've extended mind to like three
minutes if a task is going to take less
than three minutes to complete complete
they're in there and even if I'm in a
Pomodoro I'll do it like because I'm
like like if I try and SWAT this in like
why the [ __ ] does it go so nice way to
take that and it so if you're the the
rule if you follow like Francisco
scissor ellos like the original publish
you protect the Pomodoro there's a most
important thing that you do not
interrupt a Pomodoro to do something
else so you know those things down
something I found really nice way to
start a day is you have a list of like
really easy to minute tasks and the
third thing is just like doot-doot-doot
and then like by half way he did put
them in a pond
yeah yeah there's life there was the
urgent well you have to just be an adult
I suppose then just make it make
assessments but like we'll take your
break do the tasks before your next
appointment or begins and then so you've
delayed the next corridor restarting but
the risk is you get sucked in like you
start a teaming a task quite often I'll
start off that I think will take two
minutes and s two hours later you IR so
I've wanted that's related to this so
I'll do mine
so all within the Pomodoro so I feel
like I've been I must have been doing it
for like at least five years in
different types or different areas like
revision and other stuff so the I think
the the best skill I think it allows you
to to create is you look at a to-do list
so like I what I do is I look at my to
do this and look at my day and think oh
anything these 10 things today and it
gets like half three other than two of
the ten things and I have such a having
such an effective day maybe these four
and just really be really annoyed in
myself but like the reality is between
when you start with and then you finish
work there's a there's a certain amount
of a focus time you can spend and like
there are hours but you need to take
breaks to maintain that focus so you
look at that - the listen you say right
today I'm gonna do I have time to do ten
Pomodoro's so this task how many
Commodores is not gonna take me three
all right that was gonna take me to I
was it took right that's my day filled
and then you have a way to actually
assess at the end like I thought that
was gonna take me three it took me four
write all that I thought I was gonna
take me to to me so actually you can get
better looking up that's a that's a task
and that's all that's a three-prong task
yeah that's a two-pot
and you just see things as arts for
pompadours to comedones so i'll started
doing that in my focus matrix where I
said now I get them and say so in my
focus matrix tasks I have square
brackets with three one two or whatever
after the tasks so that I know of any LD
day and then you can you can build the
day planner Pomodoro's and then you've
got a map that they might have some
tasks they're like 15 Pomodoro and
there's no better feeling than doing a
three
if asking to 400 uses cuz you just
you're ahead
what's that yeah if I Pratt I'm a title
in my wallet you know the thing that the
GPS tracking thing ya know only goes off
during pod give us press on my wallet
which is here yeah with my elbow it has
a feature that allows me to find my
wallet picture by squeezing it something
else it allows you to find your wallet
by squeezing it squeezing the wallets
gonna sign here I would meet the screen
evidently it's annoying that's good
finish leave its annoying
one of the first criticisms or one of
the first arguments that Darren had so
my business partner is the perfect
avatar for someone who is genetically
predisposed to be a fantastic
businessman incredibly shrewd and like
he 80/20 is my 8020 from this right so
he just doesn't subscribe to the vast
majority the stuff but some of the
things like the trackpad speed and the
automatic carry a few other bits he's
kind of trailed down but it the first
criticism he had was well that means out
of every half an hour I'm losing five
minutes I'm like okay there's more if
you tried to work all the way here I
mean it did again it's it's simply a
lack of perspective it's like someone
who does five thirty one thinks they
don't need a deal owed yeah you're wrong
are absolutely wrong and you'll be four
five three one but the system will prove
you wrong eventually when it crushes you
nice such and pompadour is exactly the
same thing but you get a twenty five
minutes in your day and not take it
suddenly it's an hour later you've lost
all structure yeah you're on YouTube you
don't know why so just take the [ __ ]
break the follow this drum probably like
the analogy of like I'm [ __ ] hot as
you like feel mint like this one shift
command shift s command shift beat which
is like skip this current break
intervals as long as we're working I
think you're on the keyboard shortcuts
for it yeah survive I'm just like yeah
[ __ ] this watch me good double up like
every [ __ ] time
yeah so another mini hack is I have been
doing so we've mentioned Anton Creole on
this course quite on this on this
podcast quite a few times so he has a
very thorough course to learn how to
trade so I look at that and think right
ok there are there are 28 modules here
so each of them is probably an hour like
the class okay but I don't a lot of
content of like it's not like so they
say get motivated and this is like okay
so we'll hedge out the alpha with the BI
[ __ ] hello this is this is a degree
basically so all I do is when my
Pomodoro break starts I let my iPods are
still in stop my music change tab play
start the Anton video and I like get up
and make sure I'm away from my desk but
that allows me to do an hour of course
I'm trying to do and I don't even notice
it so within my breaks and it it's not
quite I can't do it all day because it
is quite cognitively demanding but it's
very different or what I've been doing
so it feels like nothing the frame shift
you can come back to the way I was doing
this and especially when it's
interesting as well
I don't think I'd be able to do that
each time see probably made for the
first four or five of the day get it
done but and then run out of gas cut me
you ate a mug like when you when you
actually that I have to have phoned out
but my my workplace environment design
now is quite good so it's like phones
away or phones in another room and I'm
controlling like wirelessly through air
pod surgeries I'm like a child then yeah
that's exactly what that's exactly our
culture I don't need it I don't need it
for my son like someone who needs go to
minute no need it for my laptop I was
like you know my facts before yeah we've
done we have tonight so the other thing
I do is start with Pomodoro you have a
different setter but I just do click a
little and what even is it the timer
thing the logo for cold turkey jerky
I was it take take the turkey start
start block what's up an iMessage 25
minutes email 25 minutes and then it
goes good do when I try and pressing it
so the number times I go to like open
iMessage reflectively or go and open
email
[Laughter]
look how fickle you are may as well be
let me pick up your phone you just don't
realize like my default if something's a
bit hard
ah just check email and before I know I
know what's happened right what we got
now this is one volunteered from Benny
who is the wonderful audio mom who does
all of their the public wastes for us
and also a good friend as well so he has
said life hacks tip no the reason I'm
prefacing with the fact that it's him
that suggested this is it this scares
the hell out of me oh my [ __ ] okay life
hack tip Chrome extension tab Wrangler
it'll alter it'll auto close tabs that
are open after a period of defined
inactivity essentially user will lose it
stop procrastinating with tabs as a
to-do list is fantastic it really scares
me that makes me that makes me really
want to go so why name so see what's
what talk me through your objection
sometimes I have tabs open as permanent
reference and now I should set up like
an Alfred shortcut maybe for it but why
aren't you talking as an Evernote file
sometimes they're like wiki websites or
whatever where you need like to the BMJ
website is - I always have my chrome
always has first one is to-do list which
aids on a card document which n I know
you guys hate but that's a separate
point and then the second the second one
is the shared ad spends Google Drive
file this comes from us over-engineering
Google to make it use it as apps that
it's not designed for yeah I know it
probably you might be listening and
thinking oh it sounds like a bunch of
excuses guys like just suck it up but
you know thank you
I think more people will be less
than thinking what the [ __ ] are they on
about why you so bothered about saving
five minutes per day why you so bothered
about having a cloud-based like ad spend
what you don't understand a person who's
watching is that this is everything to
us okay it's also everything to them
they just don't realize it
it is it's like what you see why you
need to listen to life hacks every
everyone has a bodybuilding goal they
just don't realize it
this is exactly the same thing yeah
that's a real book bear for me everyone
does huh oh no interested bodybuilding
yes Wow
yeah be less fat and who want more
muscle just because you don't want to be
Ronnie Coleman doesn't mean that you
don't have don't be running Coleman now
so so Ronald is right when he said it
Ronald and by one Budda Budda Budda
nobody want to lift him any happier sway
they don't remember has there been a
more true statement Ron Ron should have
lifted the heaviest way either shitty
anyone anything sir yeah so he watched
it no he's just a bitter oh yeah well
he's like barely walking surf Italian
was quite sad he's on the top end dose
of those real big dick painkillers the
obviously really yeah is unlike the 30s
or 40s of them like three times a day
now these changed immensely positive
still training still going into that
[ __ ] whatever it is powerhouse gym or
whatever it's called this tricep
extensions in Jeff really yeah just like
feet up benchpress
the Khan is buying his people think he's
a big caricature but I think he operates
operated and so operated a very done no
he's a very smart guy yeah but all that
like who the [ __ ] is about a double 700
pounds squat is going we're still not
taking it seriously when you're doubling
a 700 pound 300 Park kilo squat plus
it's brilliant nice soldiers to joke T
yeah
it's 800 pounds solid solid solid as per
what was what was your longest one was
the table Wrangler tab Wrangler
I for anyone else who is running a
podcast that has life hacks on a life
hack for you life hacks podcast is to do
show notes while you while you're doing
this yeah so we've already spoken about
this but I want to bring it up again and
I'm going to enjoy doing this as well I
think we need to revisit some of them
later down the road because we've gained
new viewers there's ones from life hacks
one that we need to look back oh do we
definitely do and this is one that I've
recently fallen in love with and it's
yours flume so yes Chris it's just if
you if you need to use Instagram you
shouldn't be using it on your phone my
argument to our boys is and I gave them
a sit-down about productivity the other
day in the office and I said essentially
if your phone is out while you're at
work you're not doing work and if you're
not doing work while you're at work you
might as well be at home so if you get
your phone out just go home like yeah
you can use iMessage on your laptop
whatsapp web Facebook Twitter and with
floom like the the one the last bastion
of why I need to get my phone out was
that because it's like you're not make
don't [ __ ] [ __ ] me you're not
doing work on snapchat like so so it's
just a very nice interface for Instagram
on your laptop you can post if you pay
like five pounds for the probation you
can even post photos with all of the
editing filters and all the rest of the
stuff I have no idea because it's
[ __ ] not certified by Instagram but
all of your credentials are held
securely you can have multiple accounts
to log into as it used to be that the
problem with these Instagram app so you
could only view and you couldn't post
from a laptop flew does allow you to you
can just drag photos in from you finder
yeah the only thing you can't do is
schedule but there are other apps that
you can do for that but this allows you
to share your tips so to post our photos
videos all of the functions of your
comments reply to DM so find people in
the frame you know when you post a video
in your selector like the still frame
you can do all that actually it is the
only thing that you can't do and they do
need to saw is it doesn't have what it
classes as support for temporary
messages support
temporary disappearing messages ie
anything on stories so you can't upload
to your story view stories or respond
see replies which are responses to yours
or other people's stories and for me
that probably constitutes about thirty
to fifty percent of my Instagram DMS
like you put your stories up throughout
the day and you get responses to those
frustrates and if you get a message that
says I support it unsupported which it
which is a little bit annoying but for
instance if you need to like one of the
underrated tools that people who have
big followings on Instagram should uses
essentially like direct marketing or
below the line marketing to their
followers because all of them have given
you access to their inbox but the reason
that you wouldn't do is it's so sort of
[ __ ] arduous to go through to navigate
through your on the app you swipe the
statistic message because I've got it
I've got that thumb and I've got to try
and open it up in this on the other book
with this you can just have especially
if you've got Alfred them you've got a
big fat clipboard open up a bunch of
conversations go through hey man like so
I've got a list of people that I know
have particular interests I've got buddy
called Ben who's in America so whenever
I have a podcast it's about physics that
I need to pull out so I can just
navigate to him here's a link I've got
all free saved in there and the keyboard
shortcuts within the app as well yes
come on five six whatever so another
thing that you can do which is
unbelievable for floom as well which I
wish you could do for the actual real
Instagram app is you can get rid of the
different areas so I've got rid of my
newsfeed
so you can actually get rid of other
thing from it so there's no newsfeed tab
there's no discover tab so you hasn't
have message search messages and my
profile 3 across the banner I don't know
it's just no browsing there's no like
Explorer there's no discover there's no
um newsfeed and it's just a productive
stuff just my [ __ ] every using the
command post as well so you can
right-click on someone else's photo yeah
it's got an internal it's got internal
repost function so you don't mean that
we get flume I will change the original
quality it copies the caption over face
like it so it's just opposite to what
most people use Instagram for isn't it
that's true that's where you have to be
an Instagram like you have to be trying
to be building a brand I suppose for
this after Matt's
because most people are on Instagram to
consume it but you I mean if you're an
Instagram to consume as you're also on
this channel that leads me to my life I
suppose ironically they're using
Instagram more mindfully than we are
because they're just enjoying Instagram
for the purpose of Instagram they don't
know that there's no major industry
thing like you are wasting your life
they're getting the inherent enjoyment
for so Cal Newport who's written deep
work which was out to review just
written a book called digital minimalism
so I think the three arguably four three
books that everybody should read are
atomic habits deep work and this so deep
work is the ability to focus deeply on
it on a task which is he calls like the
the superpower a superpower of just
generation yet and then building how
it's the last James quiz book is
incredible phenomenal and then the stuff
that gets in the way of that is the one
notification and Cal Newport has been
applied the same very similar framework
to basically auditing your digital life
so the book right now I'm about halfway
through he basically talks about
evaluating what is it you're trying to
achieve with a piece of software or an
app is that the best way to achieve that
outcome so like people say are I like
Facebook because I get to see my
cousin's baby photos replace that with
call your cousin once a month and the
connection will be better the cops have
a better relationship with your cousin
yeah so don't like these platforms are
designed to suck you in keep you there
get you to stay on that screen so don't
don't give them that unless it's
absolutely worth it and go through a 30
day digital detox and then evaluate what
you missed and why it's supposed to know
how you think I got introduced well like
I am because a lot of people will say
like ah well I use Facebook and it's
fine I only see the big problem yeah if
you get rescuetime and just run it for a
month don't look at it until the end of
the month and then look back and see how
much time you've absolutely pissed away
on on so using timeline phone as well
then you're like oh I see isn't it I
feel sick and entrust something I didn't
used to do
don't do any more actually is I would
total so in the Pomodoro but he
recommends tracking Pomodoro's and yet
the lock so I did it when I initially
started them I would compare time on
rescue time which is the screen time in
a week to Pomodoro time so how much time
it was like Ted living no no it was it
was like 10 plus hours across a week
yeah and I'm just like on my laptop yeah
before the [ __ ] am i do i can watch 5
films
faison on the x time plug in between
Pomodoro's and a little bit of it oh
yeah there's gonna be a number of
there's gonna be an hour a day I don't
actually know I trucked a park a class-2
Pomodoro's 30 minutes okay that's very
clever so that's so that's just so ICT
Pomodoro's as an hour of work yeah
essentially yeah okay that'd be a little
bit the minimalism so I'm frightening
scary yeah most people wouldn't do or
something
how how um ruthless because Cal Newport
is like you don't need to be on social
media to build a brand you don't need to
be live scene is it a TED talk that you
gave mm-hmm where it's like about how
and these are the common reasons as to
why people say that they can't get off
social media hmm like [ __ ] out Cal
like it's like pressing buttons the 50
Cal like yeah
headshot because it he uses an example
of a guy who's like trying to build his
like he's basic guitarist he's trying to
build his brand on social media and just
lists reasons as to why I like lots of
guys excuses
yeah even an tonk real right how's the
section where he's like get rid of your
smartphone I don't care what your
reasons are just get rid of your
smartphone I used a Nokia 82 10 and it's
less that it stores 50 numbers and SMS
but he tweets a lot so he has his wife
manages Instagram ya know he does a lot
though he retweets to say his rulers Z
right wanna go paper or sketched like do
all of your work on Facebook Twitter
once a week scheduler impossible you
think he's doing a you it's impossible
for him it's impossible II think he's
uploading stuff last quote he's called
tweeting stuff that occurred within
maybe maybe he was violating his own
room he must be like cause he's too
responsive right online
like you can't schedule a quality
[ __ ] you it's possible he does have a
media team so it is possible because he
has a guy knowledge is maybe he's
unequivocally in his toe in it okay
we've rumbled him yeah but then I don't
know and like it seems to me especially
like there's that quote no one is ever
too busy to tell you how busy they are
it's like no one is ever so few people
are to digitally minimal to not care
about being on Twitter like Navarre
Rebecca like bro mmm you are without a
doubt one of the biggest dicks there
I've ever seen in my life spend a lot of
time on Twitter still I don't use a
Twitter there's an interest me too all
me neither
it's and what George Michaela long dick
swinging yeah George Michaela he'll be
listening is is he's leveraging off this
right like he's leveraging off this
hyper aphorism like 360 character life
[ __ ] advice stuff that's going on and
like for the people that like to consume
that then cool but I've got a couple of
problems with it first one is it's not
context and it's like [ __ ] why does
an inspirational partner change your
life in cycle because time and attention
like as it matters and then the other
thing is the the dick measuring thing or
the dick swinging thing like it just
becomes everything so pithy and it's
like it you can just tweet stuff that
doesn't have to be like better than you
and this is change your world and like
mate like Twitter was well I mean it's
an innovative way to use a platform I've
had Yousef are rather like listen to
those people in a lungful on for podcast
or like buy that book or are you saying
the other day that books are the value
you get from a book for like 5 quid so
absolutely it's a business life work and
they've spent years editing and writing
it out and formulating their idea they
should be in the neighborhood quit the
tweet has just been brushed out or like
a ya know it's just it's so that's right
by 25,000 people that's crazy you know
the thing I suppose that you don't that
are certainly before we started using
these things with businesses you don't
see as a user is that the way the
platforms work is in
courage is a race to the bottom with
clickbait yeah for people to get seen on
the field at the so Tristan Harris was
centrist on was saying how the emotion
of outrage is algorithmically the most
successful thing second the only thing
which comes second to it is like hyper
agreement okay yeah so you end up either
with things which superbly support your
view which is why I violate mister like
the anti-vaxxer groups become these
crazy circle jokes of like you know
someone someone posted I think I must in
here on the screenshot someone said ah
like I've I've been diagnosed with
sepsis and like I'm critically ill what
what should I do
I don't want to take antibiotics if
someone was commenting mean that oh yeah
just take high dose vitamin C and you'll
be it's like that is faithful advice
that killed your friends yeah but
because you're in this echo chamber of
all year school antibiotics that's just
Big Pharma trying it's so you end up
with these like pockets of people that
are just hyper agreeing with each other
and it becomes there was something of a
woman did you send it to me with the
kids a woman whose kid how to manage
eyes or something yeah I didn't get in
vaccinated and he's got the disease what
what do i do yeah it's so it's like so
don't build this argument and then back
truck the oh my roughing the doctor I
was working with yesterday said that she
was on a plane and someone had basically
a sudden onset severe pain in the in
their like lower chest upper upper
stomach area which could be a number of
things that obviously quite quite quite
dangerous and severe she went over to
attend to the patient and she felt this
person just like standing behind her and
she was like no no I you need to get
some chillies least get some chillies
four inches I'm sorry what I'm a
herbalist he needs chillies because she
was like ok this guy's got a bleed in
the stomach potentially you want to give
him chillies also we're on a plane like
the kitchen's like go away yeah I
appreciate you wanting to help but so
Brian Cox said that in his presentation
someone said like Karim is the question
it was something like do you think
there's a downside to science or
something anyone yeah I mean if you
misinterpret things in for example you
know you think vaccines about or
something like that then yes that is bad
but I just thought like the way that he
just just gives me a time of the day
like it's not even have you listened to
mine if he careful if you listen to him
on Joe Rogan no I want to man either he
is I'd forgotten how much of a
[ __ ] he is and you don't because
you presume that like [ __ ] Carlo
Rovelli or some of these more kind of
backroom physicists and like you
discredit me Oh deGrasse Tyson just
because of how that prolific he is you
presume like you think that Grylls isn't
hard you like no egg rolls with [ __ ] you
what yeah like eggsy so mainstream yeah
and you forget like and that's the
equivalent of being the best in your
field the equipment have been the cream
of the crop and yeah maybe like if you
need down with into one area of bears
like like survivalism he might not be as
good or [ __ ] of the building he might
not be as good as this guy you know
particle physics or like whatever like
astrobiology what's-his-face might not
be quite so good be like if you want to
take a [ __ ] broad spectrum view he's
got like it's a cosmic sized schwa isn't
it yeah yeah the thing that's what was
mental about it was it's Friday night
and there's a stadium on a stadium an
arena full of people listening to a
physicist explain space-time and like as
I was leaving
so like I'm stuck as a moment where I
realized like this is not gonna be a
relaxing night not two hours and you go
from this like right but okay attention
here are the [ __ ] hell this is no
roller coaster on and it's lovely that
exists on a large scale and there's not
become a kind of worry she's right I
look around you think all these people
are here to listen to sold-out explain
space-time and like I find that really
interesting but I can't believe that I'm
that there's enough of a majority and
then as you're leaving here
I don't know any other but these still
like Rob this look Johnny yeah the the
brown [ __ ] things makes a little bit
more sense to me than the Petersons Sam
Harris Eric Weinstein thing so like how
many people were there 10,000 20,000 no
I don't know 5,000 I don't know I feel
like your boots or person we give I
don't know how many I don't know how
many stands were open I don't know how
far we've taken it yeah if there's
anyone I trust to look at a crowd of
people but I could tell you I can tell
you if I don't know how much so anyway
it was about it was a little way off the
end and there was sitting all the way up
and in the center right so was he at the
very very end of the Metro Radio loner
no right halfway I look at the pass off
worth it
right okay so that deviant okay so that
would be probably the same as that for
Cirque du Soleil which would be like if
you got pulled up onto the stage I got
made to go up on stage and dressed up as
a woman here in front of a few thousand
people so I reckon let's say that
there's 5,000 people in his show maybe
more might actually become a little a
50-quid yes I mean that but that's crazy
but when me and George went to go see
John Peterson like III get Brian Cox
just a little bit more when he's on TV
you've got the mainstream in a
mainstream TV there's a big audio-visual
element to it like it it's a glorified
roller coaster yeah
Jordan Peterson was him just him and his
massive [ __ ] spindly fingers just
talking about archetypes and Cooling
everyone in the crowd these fan ads and
how many people over 3,000 between two
and three thousand all eagerly wanted
John Peterson break down his income No
whereas if tis on YouTube so there's a
video where he gets interviewed by a
French reporter oh yeah yeah yeah we're
on the trigger envelope yeah so he the
French reporter asks and expose his
finances really okay I will sure um he's
got pretty big business for what I
assume is a like him and maybe one or
two other people called future future
author and sweet and undecided he's
making like he's basically making a
million quid here
of patreon yeah well not at all not
anymore but at the time the video he was
yeah and then like he went through book
sales and events and stuff like that
terrifying it's big numbers like much
bigger than objects so the foot the
funny thing about that Joe Rogan alludes
to all the time is that he says like the
left [ __ ] with the wrong person like
if you were gonna pick someone to [ __ ]
or to not [ __ ] with em it would be
Jordan Peterson like okay we're gonna
just like poke this frog and see what
happens
the pikmin venomous ones and you're like
oh my god it is from this frogs turn
into probably what's it worth an hour
maybe like 10 to 20 mil probably mostly
and it wouldn't have happened unless it
was like oh my god and he's just
watching him growing in this huge
[ __ ] towering like yeah monster
groans lime and he can fly this a
Leviathan comes out over the top of you
boy he's got these huge [ __ ] with
fingers and he's waving him around and
you're like oh my god now he's rich oh
now he's left patreon and you're like
when he starts up his own version and so
he's grown because his dicks too big yes
just like what do you mean even when his
shoulder him in some areas gonna start
their own version of subscribe star on
patreon
like when that happens they're going to
be taking a percentage of everyone that
moves over there
everyone [ __ ] loves them this is
something Dale Garrett white who I
imagine will not have been on yet he
will have probably or maybe maybe just
something that he spoke spoke about with
regards so like trying to get a message
to people it's like people try and do
charity events and things like that but
like what really makes a difference is
the bloke with ten million quid I might
use can't argue with that
because like you can do whatever you
want and like Tony Hawk pack bags at
Morrison's but if there's a bloke with
ten million quid he wants to get a
message out he's going to win every
single day and so as John Peterson's
progressively gets richer it's gonna be
harder and harder to shut it like if I
start certain pay traffic behind stuff
it's just just the stuff you leave it
can you imagine can you imagine if
you're denied
click footages from big red livre
russell brunson going like okay he's
also he loves a fight doesn't he so i
wasn't that interview at the French
reporter like the French report gives
him a bit [ __ ] and he just shuts him
down you think oh yeah yeah don't poke
about and so he said he says this really
this really interesting thing I think it
was on Joe Rogan again as well where he
was talking about how he he's happy to
have the fight but he is natural
proclivity isn't to that and he says it
takes him a couple of days to recover so
you spoke specifically about the GQ
interview right the woman which was like
Kathy Newman got sent away trained for a
while like came back with a 220 deadlift
and and like that she had notes with her
and they didn't give him a microphone
it's with GQ microaggressions Jews
didn't realize that it was like Yuri
Belkin meets Tom Martin yeah yeah it was
it was UFC one all over the road
and so he had that he's referring to
that and he goes um it took me like two
days to kind of recover from that
because the and you are right like he's
able to keep his cool to a degree that
like I've never ever seen anyone like
even Sam Harris lost his [ __ ] like he
does it was been very conscious of the
fact that he lost issue yeah he'll watch
himself
sorry I'm just segue massive behave if
you heard the story about when Sam
Harris ended up Cain like to articles
came out about him at the same time was
that to hit pieces he's on holiday in
Hawaii no no it was family yeah either
this family and he just top he does his
own holiday so he'd had this exchange
hang himself torpedoes oh no though he'd
had this exchange back and forth with
Ezra Klein from Vox and he'd had this
thing is that remember him tearing apart
as recline on their podcast later with
them they sat down had this podcast had
Tony
Ezra Ezra Ezra like please in the
interests of everybody's sanity that's
listening and but like the way it goes
on and uh but it's basically his idea
was I'm on holiday this has really
annoyed me [ __ ] what do i do I also like
my wife's here like so I'm gonna get in
the doghouse for keep on doing this
which is nice to know that somehow I
still like has to suffer with stuff like
that yeah you know things like um so
yeah and he's he's saying that his his
solution was to just publish the email
exchange so to have this big email
exchange big long one just like scroll
screen shot scrolled screenshots curled
screen shot like just wet and just
published out but didn't really like
double check how it looked and because
there wasn't any context behind that
that made him look even worse and then
he just sucked tweet thumb down face
down like on the table came back to it a
couple of hours later and like all hell
had broken loose and you like [ __ ] it's
just not it's nice to know that people
like everyone has to take me mr. mind so
we're still on the set all the hell
going loose just by like tiresome and
also author hasn't broken loose it's
just different things happen on screen
yeah true if you take a very sensory
view of it it's like yeah that's all
just listen some like so was like your
digital minimalism in video yeah mine is
an app called so you guys even hate this
basically spotty free
so even vxd because this shakiness
actually they're pushing I think I'm
just gonna have to go so guys what a
spotter free does is if you have this is
even set off Johnny's tile if you have
it Spotify free and you hate the really
intrusive quite loud adverts like the
the volume on mean that you mean that
you mean they're earning their earning
potential yes Chris is like had to rely
right in the thing so normally the its
music and then it's like hey well good
room and better than those box of the
music any higher
let's just blow my head off what spot of
free does is it just detects one and
adverts coming and just mutes Spotify
for 30 seconds so it doesn't speed up
the way that you played music it just
gives you face it doesn't allow you to
play songs within playlists without it
being on random now you can sit on the
desktop version so then this is
Spotify's a desktop app you get full
function Spotify apart from being able
to play at the same time on multiple
devices and you can't do it okay I think
that will do I'll do one more then we'll
do it put your fire around okay no I
think no see the most neat just popping
off I don't really use on so would you
listen to new podcasts or just buy music
do you know something like I'm with it
for t-shir so Phillips sunrise lamp bang
absolute [ __ ] game changer so
especially if you are from the UK and
you don't get an awful lot of sunlight
you'll know that seasonal affective
disorder sad is a real thing like I
definitely feel better in the summer and
worse in the winter yeah one of the
reasons for that is your natural
circadian rhythm gets thrown off due to
melatonin production that is dictated by
the amount of light exposure that you
get a solution to that are these like
indoor Sun lamps that you can get that
are measured in lumens and they match
the particular tone of sunlight outside
and you expose yourself to a particular
amount of time so the right lamps aren't
bright enough even this one which is
like the biggest dick one that you can
get it's not bright enough for that to
make a real difference but for me it's
it's enough to kind of make me think
that it's gonna help that so the main
thing is it's the same as a radio alarm
clock that you would have normally but
it's got a bright as [ __ ] light which is
a similar hue to what you will get on
daylight that comes up before the sound
goes off
so it means that you are able to wake up
due to light as opposed to due to sound
and then also can fire out like nature
sounds or whatever is at the end of it
but for me that it's the same as people
that don't work in Pomodoro's like if
you're waking up to sound now like why
is this like didn't [ __ ] 1800 oh yeah
man why don't you just like go and get
someone to ring a bell at the local
church tower outside of your window yeah
like so you set away for a particular
time and it will slowly begin to
increase the intensity of the light over
a half an hour period before you wake up
and what that'll also do is play around
with your cortisol level on a morning
and also your melatonin release in an
effort to ready your body to be awake as
opposed to sometimes especially if you
if you're not using like sleep cycle
which you'll use your sleep waves to
then also try and type things in if
you're not using either of these you're
potentially in the middle of deep sleep
and just gain like right wrench out of
it which is not a nice feeling there'll
be some days when you will wake up and
you'll be like oh my god like if you
feel drunk yeah you try and wake up
whereas agonizing sometimes like the
pain that you gave up on weight you're
like that's hard to turn around as well
I don't think I ever have like a
productive morning or day if I've woken
up feeling like that [ __ ] yeah so
Phillips sunrise lampa there's also
there's a number of other signs that you
can do free it's got a sunset setting
which is quite nice so again when you go
to bed you can press 10 minutes and it
will go down from it current brightness
to zero it's got a couple of other
things as well where it's got a very
very low light way of displaying the
time at night I know this sounds so like
finicky tea but you don't realize just
how much light like a normal LCD clock
will actually give us so now if it's a
[ __ ] red one like you know one of
those thank you Bob and dad will have
one and you're like this is this is
brighter than it is during the day like
if it's all red you feel like you're in
a Tom Clancy movie and someone's gonna
like Rainbow six you dory
lazy good so yeah this that's really low
I've now taken this to another another
level of anal and have got a second son
rise up of a different brand of the far
side of the room nice reason for that is
that my new year's resolution is no fun
in my bedroom my your energy if you just
have it's like an asymmetric risk if you
only have one alarm clock I needed a
second alarm clock but I couldn't use my
phone I also I also couldn't use one
when you literally bought another alarm
[ __ ] but the thing is as well I couldn't
buy another Phillips sunrise laughs
because if the power goes off that I'm
[ __ ] still so what I've got is and
it's only about 30 queries if you don't
have 100 and like 20 quid spend on a
filter sunrise art this will be a
moderately adequate alternative it's
just a cheaper version of it but the
crucial thing this has is you put three
Triple A batteries in and if the power
gets killed so it'll kick in on that
that's cool some like your backup power
I've got a backup thing which I mean
like I think the other thing as well is
like I wake up at the time when I tell
myself to wake up like the only thing
that I'll miss like if the power went
off in the house all that would happen
is miss my morning routine and I go it's
very rare I have to get up to anything
other than my desire to wake up the best
insurance against against that this is
just wake up at the same time every day
because eventually like you know now I
wake up pretty much every day before any
alarm goes off and you get ready to be
tired at the same time I dream for the
day when that's gonna be the case but
for me that's not so we're now doing
quick fire quickfire either mine feeds
off that which is that I'm on second
stint of no caffeine but now I think I'm
just gonna make it Peyman really what up
I'll explain so the first summer that it
was the day challenge my girlfriend said
I bet you can't go for three days
without coffee so funky as I can so I
would never thirty day and see the day
without without coffee
without coffee at all so that included
decaf coffee
I really like coffee so found that very
difficult tried lots of different teas
nothing was that great this time so then
slowly slipped back into you say you
start with one coffee there are some
another one and you're back to for
coffee sir like back to where I started
so start this year I was like 1st of
January me and you me I'll just stop
having coffee you see what happens sup
I'm coffee
so now I've had caffeine on three
occasions all of them have been
pre-workout on all those sessions I hit
a big TV so I think like very large PBS
yeah so for the first time ever I think
apart from like maybe the first
pre-workout ever have I'm experiencing
the performance-enhancing benefits of
caffeine okay and on a daily basis we
talk through the pee because I think
okay sure so the way it happened was I
was going to Train slightly later than
normal it's big squat session thought
I'm feeling the tight I'll just have our
coffees had an espresso a single
espresso got into training squat 200 200
goes down two hundred fires back up
again and I was like what the [ __ ] just
happened there like that wasn't
expecting it to none of our same thing
happened to 230 same thing 240 was like
the same speed 220 would normally be
like okay 220 back on the bar I'm gonna
do a set of 5 did four and I thought I'm
just gonna hit a PBS so 224 6 as a PB
hit 7 probably had another 2 or 3 in the
tank I was like this is this is
ridiculous so it'll be a one-off a
couple days go by
same thing happens with bench so it
right caffeine again same thing
deadlift same thing so okay caffeine is
a very powerful thing so on an on a
daily basis now I'll just have decaf
coffee and I don't honestly don't notice
any change other than decaf coffee you
drink so quite particular this so lose
burn coffee if you live in you probably
get it anywhere I suppose but they're
decaf coffee is genuinely nice as is the
stuff you can buy in a Starbucks so
Starbucks decaf coffee so you're not
making anything at home yeah
I grind grind the beans make it with an
Arabic coffee company what is it just
normal decaf just the beans so that I've
got a bit Keillor bag of the beans then
they only have one just a cup of beans
just got we cover because they used to
these groups yeah they've got they've
got like 12 caffeinated variations and
then Dione right okay so the you know I
will do I ask the same with most first
round Gupta school good we know right
decaf coffee at the same time have also
gone so that's another conversation
conversation I'm so yeah but that was
your influence I'm the nice things it's
it's the you are he's still gonna have
it pre-training I think I'll probably
use it strategically for big stations or
like competitions so how did you sleep
below the post cause of it so that was
what I was leading on from from that
like the for me I realized that I only
realized after giving coffee up that
caffeine up the consistent wait times
are really difficult with caffeine
because you don't so to be clear like I
was the person telling you self use
pathetic perfect avatar for not having
caffeine and always used to think that
it didn't it wasn't making a difference
but you don't realize how much of a
difference it's making until you is so
annoying I really wish it didn't last
that long
I wish there was an unlocked zone for
caffeine like an antidote to just just
never a new turret you know I could I
found some my caffeine usage tends to be
once a day mmm first thing in the
morning
mostly because I like it and also I do I
do feel like I need that kick I also
train in the morning as well but I
genuinely like on a night time now like
my eyes are drooping not only one and a
I think podcast is with dr. Greg Potter
he his advice and he [ __ ] knows what
he's talking about if you have nine
hours before like that should be your
bottom end of where you prepared to take
it I mean I'm sure that there will still
be some sort of effects downstream if
you have one at 6:00 a.m. and you go to
bed at 9:00 p.m. at night but I'm gonna
hope that you'll probably be able to
mitigate most yeah it's always just dose
dependent I think as well yeah I feel
like yeah I mean I definitely and I
think I think I'm the standard office
work is having a lot
anyone who's having caffeine after 5
p.m. like Darrin will go out for dinner
yeah and then another man dr. coffee you
know after a restaurant meal it it
completely bubbles me so ever since then
has a theory that so he will do that and
doesn't feel anything doesn't affect his
sleep isn't that all about coffee and he
thinks that his girlfriend is like me
loves coffee and the food we couldn't
get to sleep so he thinks it's just
people who are really responsive people
who aren't responsive but there are
responses that are still having an
impact but this was more safe
subjectively I don't feel like there's
much difference but you also don't feel
the amount the percentage of REM sleep
that you get in the area so so he might
be able to get to sleep and say yeah he
doesn't fit like from his mind doesn't
open but they don't necessarily feel
dietary fat or sugar or protein so it's
it's still funny yes exactly and it was
only when I started drinking coffee that
I started to fall asleep so like last
year I had it just a couple and I
started falling asleep during the day
and I never fall asleep during the day
normally and it was just because the
knock-on effect of the reduced sleep
quality that night oh yeah especially
this summer here so you're maybe link to
your video about vitamin D and caffeine
ones no sunlight and how that can become
a mmm negative spiral I think just just
try it I suppose yeah and a lot of
coffee the first week is hellish well if
you do Johnny's Cuddy caffeine protocol
yeah that we've done our Instagram have
a look then by is harder to make it
seamless is anything notice it's
happening yeah it is or you can rip the
band-aid off and go maybe super mode so
speaking of seemed endless I am no [ __ ]
my life pipe is cut a tennis ball in
half I was just joking about no fun but
if you have a door that often hits the
wall makes a hole in the plaster coat
tennis ball in half super glue it to the
wall looks like a nice little abstract
bit of art on your wall so that's that's
one good thing and also the door could
pass off the tennis ball and doorstop
yeah
let's do all the doorstop but like the
heavy heavy brass things that you stick
in the floor no I was thinking more like
a wedge well just any doorstop that's
built you're not gonna remove the paint
on your wall
this is for my front door so yeah so I
just I just think that there will be a
lot of people who are very particular
about how they've decorated the house
mm-hmm it's always a conversation piece
are you there oh okay that's so clever
yeah okay yeah okay I'm given the choice
at zany it is given given the choice
between a hole in the wall and half
tennis ball on the wall that's what it
was so I covered up an existing hole
no-brainer yeah I just thought what
photo school depends it's a superfood
can we link that clip video monday we'll
make it work we have a here deep [ __ ] to
scoop the beans for these like alright
right
consult a new picture the new Alan
Partridge is coming out soon and we're
all very excited
okay so my my friend one is as a
gentleman treat yourself with a sit down
we oh yes okay I just I think it's an
underused you don't worry about your
Winky touching there the toilet itself
inside of the bowl mm-hmm especially on
my toy I know that my toilets very clean
the the previous owners of this house
when they had the downstairs toilet
fitted they plumbed the cistern of the
downstairs toilet into the hot water not
into the cold and it it gets pretty
clean steamy in the winter yeah there is
steam I think if they probably be quite
nice actually
it's pretty nice pretty well thank you
yeah the effect you build I suppose you
don't know do you [ __ ] off you never
you never not had it so yeah I don't
know I die I don't flush that much it's
a small gem in such a small amount of
water
um but yeah sit down we like especially
you know I guess there's a girl like
you've got understandably
how was it dumping
we cannot be a stand-up who I - right
I've seen a guy take a stand up poo can
you stand up he's what in full except
she's mental he he's got to really large
testicles because he always gets them
out is it that guy that calls it the
brain no but yeah right he I was a I had
a party at my house and when I left my
room he slipped into my bed naked and
was our mate you get me kind of coke but
no get out mother there's something
naked and he is just always like doing
this bit of an exhibitionist yeah like
there was a house viewing and like
students coming into view is house near
sat in this room masturbating I think
knowingly like I mean this is quite
makes me sound like a real offender yeah
anyway probably masturbating in the
Antarctic poof yo yeah this under poo
especially especially as well you know
like if you wake up I don't know whether
you you guys get this going on from a
sleep thing you know when you wake up at
like 5:00 a.m. relations for mmm no five
ever for a diva's think five eight
before iam and you don't want to show
you allow yourself to pass the upper
threshold of wakefulness because if you
do if you start to like deployed too
much cognitive power and to move around
so you like hate yourself to me like
benefit to sit down tweeze yes yeah
absolutely because you can just sit and
you're like ah at least it's going in
hands or rest on your knees
everyone's and contemplate your own
mortality while you're having a
stateless [ __ ] yeah but someone
someone packed up actually we've got to
finish Africa but one that was submitted
in the comments and that called me and
Daniel schloss amateurs for saying that
we have to work ourselves up to shave
our ourselves
and said both years are absolute
amateurs feet sensitive really like just
feet the full thing washes on it so then
I thought it was gonna go down the route
of like just go straight in with what
well you were saying is he he was
implying you said you have to work
yourself up to it work yourself up to
like the bravery to put a shaver down
there yeah I'm saying so I thought he
was gonna say there are okay
the only so I suppose the thing with
using feet like a hair removal cream
versus my estrogen no no everything
everything I'm sure it does it's just
the like one is the temporary solution
whereas waxing is like permanently
weakening the follicles and so
eventually you don't have to shave what
is going on what is that why is it so
some tile I think this is a life fail
here's a wife [ __ ] [ __ ] it's
definitely use any bike for yourself it
was a Christmas present a year and a bit
ago do you like like [ __ ] it's a sort of
thing I do need but but since then
knowingly I've established a very
consistent routine with where I put my
wallet and so here's a good point for a
little bit of a life fail I came in once
like I always have the same routine when
I come in in the kitchen bag goes down
here open the door bag goes down etc etc
everything has it to place it's just
idiosyncratic now don't think about it
once came into the living room lost my
keys for half a day Joyce came into the
living room say hi T to Lewis and I was
like what the [ __ ] is half as easy just
taken care of by automatic behavior and
that's the rail that's a [ __ ]
thank you very much for tuning it don't
forget comment below with your favorite
life hacks we will give you potentially
hundred fifty pounds worth from the
protein work sensor protein works for
sponsoring this episode we will be back
very very soon with an awful lot of
different things links to everything
will be in the show notes below and also
if there's any referral codes and things
like that we'll try and find them any
discounts will be in there as well share
the episodes like the episodes
right Kaiba
[Music]
you